[Aplausos]
[Música]
y si empezamos a vivir con compasión
soy las típicas personas que reflexiona
absolutamente de todo lo que le pase en
la vida soy psicóloga y es inevitable
para mí ante cualquier situación que
pasa empezar a pensar porque pase esa
cosa o cuáles fueron las cosas que
motivaron para que pasara tal mortal
situación no
de un tiempo para acá empezar a tener un
hobby en donde cualquier cosa ha pasado
en mi vida y pues eso no lo empezó a
reflexionar una vez me quemé y lo
relacione en como las camadas físicas
tienen una relación como las heridas
emocionales no como si no tipo limpiamos
lo que tenemos pues siempre va a
infectarse un poquito más reflexione
también como en la vida te saltas cosas
y un día platicando con una amiga empecé
a platicar con ellas sobre el amor en
las relaciones y me empezó a contar una
historia en donde una vez y estaba en su
depa con unos amigos y se empezaron a ir
todos y se quedó platicando nada más con
un amigo y justo en ese momento
empezaron a compartir cosas íntimas y
habló de intimidad como aquellas cosas
que no le cuentes a todas las personas
tus heridas
tus fracasos tus éxitos también tus
sueños pero no cosas que no compartes
con todo el mundo cosas en donde te
atreves a compartirlo y nace como que el
compartir con estas personas me cuenta
que en este momento empezaron a
compartir todas estas cosas empezaron a
compartir intimidad
hubo una demostración física de expósito
de esa intimidad no hubo pues un beso
hubo caricias entonces dijo pues que
padre o sea logre conectar con esta
persona pasan los días y se vuelve a
encontrar con este chavo pero ya no hay
esa conexión inicial ya no hacen ese
intercambio de de sueños ya no hacen ese
intercambio de heridas ya no como que
conectan otra vez sino que simplemente
se salta en ese paso y solamente tienen
un encuentro físico vuelve a pasar otra
vez lo mismo en otra ocasión que se
encuentran y qué pasa en vez de unirse
empiezan a separarse poco a poco
empiezan a separarse yo me empecé a
pensar como que era todo esto en la
intimidad y porque en vez de unir si no
la utilizamos bien y si creemos que la
intimidad es un encuentro físico en un
encuentro emocional empezamos a
separarnos en vez de empezar a unir con
las personas porque les cuento esta
historia porque creo que creando
intimidad con las demás personas podemos
transformar nuestra sociedad porque
pienso esto
creo que es real la intimidad cuando tú
te atreves a compartir un poco de lo que
tú trayendo cuando tú te atreves a
quitarte la armadura que el mundo nos
dice que tengamos y que a veces no se
estimula que la tengamos la gente nos
dice tienes que ser fuerte
la debilidad no es buena entonces qué
pasa nos estamos protegiendo con todo el
mundo y el mundo refuerza que se hace
eso las empresas refuerzan que no seas
débil quien aquí es papá el hijo no
puede ser débil tienes que ser fuerte
siempre
a cuantos personas nos dijeron eso
alguna vez no y que vamos creciendo con
eso pues tengo que ser fuerte y si
muestro cualquier cosa de habilidad pues
no va a ser exitoso
entonces el mundo nos está contagiando
que tenemos que vivir con armadoras toda
la vida y si buscan armaduras no podemos
tener intimidad con las personas y si no
tenemos intimidad con las personas no
podemos ser vulnerables no damos ese
paso de vulnerabilidad tenemos una
situación de vulnerabilidad y empezamos
a dar este paso decimos hijo les mejor
no porque qué miedo
qué miedo decirle lo que siento que es
miedo postular me parece puesto y que me
diga no no eres buena que me va
arriesgarme decirle te quiero
qué miedo nos da miedo no entonces no
nos hacemos vulnerables y si no somos
capaz de hacernos vulnerables no somos
capaces de generar empatía con los demás
yo no me permito sentir a mí misma y si
yo no me permita sentir a mí misma como
voy a permitirme sentir con el otro como
voy a ser capaz de sentir con el otro
vivimos en un mundo egoísta
tú no generamos empatía con las demás
personas y qué pasa cuando tú generas
empatía sientes con el otro no y cuál es
el siguiente paso de la empatía la
compasión pero no hablo una compasión de
ay qué pena pobrecito y ahí se queda no
ya sentí contigo y a sentir lo que estás
tú sintiendo soy capaz de salir de mí
misma y tomar una acción y actuar para
ayudarte pero todo esto viene de que yo
me permití sentir a mí mismo
una compasión que es necesario primero
que nada conocerte a ti misma que voy a
compartir si no sé quién soy
para que eres buena que talentos tienes
lo que hablar ahorita adrián también no
como yo puedo tomar una acción de lo que
soy y redireccionar y encauzar todos mis
talentos para cambiar una parte del
mundo a veces queremos hacer cosas
grandes cosas grandes pero nos olvidamos
hacer cosas siempre y cosas sencillas
creo que ya la intimidad con las demás
personas podemos transformar el mundo y
hablar transformar no cambiar creo que
estos nos venden esta idea de que
tenemos que cambiar el mundo pero pues
cambiar el mundo si nos damos con esta
relación tengo que cambiar y yo entonces
porque nací con 'la con mis talentos y
porque nací con todas estas cosas no se
nos que transformar y estar en continua
transformación de nosotros mismos no
cambiando nos transformarme a mí para
transformar la sociedad transformar el
mundo para transformar el mundo tengo
que transformar la sociedad
mi sociedad donde yo me muevo con los
que me relaciono y para transformar la
sociedad todo que empezar con mi familia
iba a transformar mi familia me tengo
que transformar y yo
piense cada uno con las personas que
tienen intimidad
como son con ellas que les cuentan
super importante esto también hablando
de un poquito de la vulnerabilidad
porque a veces creemos que tenemos que
compartir todo y no todo el mundo se
merece o no todo el mundo tiene el
privilegio de saber tus heridas tu
historia tus fracasos pero tienes que
encontrar a alguien con quien lo puedas
hacer y tienes que dejarte y permitirte
hacerlo
porque si no no lo vas a hacer por todas
las personas no
tengo estaba leyendo un libro y me
encantó porque en el prólogo tiene una
historia de un señor un empresario que
tenía muchísima competencia y toda la
competencia quería como verlo fracasar
entonces él junto a todos sus empleados
y les llevaron un speech de cómo
motivarlos y de cuál iba a ser el rumbo
de su empresa entonces llega a las
posiciones que tengo que ir a comprar
pos todo lo del súper para para darles
de comer y el vinito y todo esto no
entonces realice pues es que no pues yo
tengo que hacer mi speech de lo que les
voy a decir de cómo los voy a motivar
total al final las señoras de val súper
y el señor se queda trabajando pero
resulta que tenían a un niño de cinco
años entonces llega el niño de que papá
papá pues ya no quiero jugar contigo el
papá que sé es que no puedo jugar
contigo porque tengo que hacer mi speed
no entonces se me dice cómo le
entretengo como la entretengo con la
entretengo agarra una revista empieza a
hojear la idea un mapa del mundo
entonces claro mi hijo de cinco años no
va a saber armar un mapa del mundo lo
corten mil pedacitos lo pone en el piso
y después mijito dármelo
unas dos horas en lo que encuentra como
arma el rompecabezas se vuelve a hacer
eso speed y regresa el niño a los cinco
minutos y luego de que con el mapamundi
armado y el mapa que como lo hiciste y
el niño le dice ay pues muy fácil
resulta que del otro lado de la hoja
estaba la cara de una persona yo no sé
cómo armar el mundo yo no sé cómo
estructurar todo el mundo pero sé cómo
armar la cara de una persona en el papa
reflexiona y dice view que teman right
but the well right entonces si nosotros
estamos bien el mundo debe ser bien
porque el mundo lo hacemos cada uno de
nosotros porque yo soy mundo sino poder
mundo si no serlo no puede haber mundo y
si el mundo está bien si yo estoy bien
el mundo va a estar bien y si empezamos
a vivir con compasión
y si empezamos a vivir con empatía
y si empezamos a sentir
y si nos empezamos a permitirse sentir
lo estaba escuchando que se lo
recomiendo ampliamente a venir round con
todo esto de la vulnerabilidad y hablaba
de que al final todo está conectado con
la vulnerabilidad todo está conectado
con la empatía si quieres tener empresas
exitosas si quieres que tu gente sea
creativa si quieres que tu agente sea
compasivo tienes que ser vulnerable
tienes que permitirles dar la opción de
equivocarse
tenemos que salir de nosotros mismos
tenemos que dejar de ser egoístas porque
es el único camino para transformar el
mundo vivimos en un mundo muy egoísta
tenemos que empezar a transformar y esa
transformación empieza con nosotras
mismas vivamos la compasión salgamos de
nuestra zona de confort y la zona de
confort es de dejarme a mí sentido
porque cuando yo no permito sentirlo
estoy mismo en el confort a lo mejor no
me arriesgo me conozco salvo soy
compasiva y comparto lo que yo tengo
empezamos a vivir con compasión así
[Aplausos]
[Música]